[Music]
i was born with a strange
gift the ability to see
what no human being has ever seen before
it's all mixed up in my head the images
the sounds the smell
[Music]
i need to remember
put things in order right up to this
moment
remember who i am if i had to say how it
all began
[Music]
i might just as well start here
i found you by the side of the road in
the middle of nowhere
was there an accident
did someone try to hurt you
how about a name someone i could contact
you must have family friends
someone who could tell me who you are
hey
you don't talk much do you
well if you don't help me i can't help
you
oh i get nowhere
is that a scar
is that a reason
[Music]
we've got to stop them they have no idea
what they're up against tell them to
wait until i get there
get back to them immediately you hear me
you've got to stop them
goddamn fools
i know
they're coming
hold on what's going on girl you brought
in earlier where is she
so
[Music]
jody what have you done
[Music]
ah there you are
how you doing today jody good
i hate to bother you when you're playing
and all but uh
i believe it's time honey
come on girl you'll have plenty of time
to play later
all right nathan's waiting for us
oh come on i don't have any more coal
seriously
it's nearly ready was due two weeks ago
i said it's nearly ready hello precious
don't you look pretty today
it's gonna rain this weekend here we are
hey jody how's your day been so far
pretty good
okay we're gonna put this on now
remember
it's just like a crown
oh yeah oh
now you're a little princess
don't worry everything's gonna be fine
i'm right next door if you need me okay
hey jody can you hear me
okay let's start kathleen is next door
and she has the same cards as you and
we're gonna get her to choose one
and see if you can tell us which one she
chose
you think you can do that
[Music]
good all right let's go for it
first card
subject's heartbeat slows to 45 beats
per minute
as an increase in theta brain waves to
4.5 hertz
the ambient temperatures drop 10 degrees
[Music]
next card
[Music]
[Music]
next card
[Music]
very good jody let's try something else
there's some building blocks on the
table in the other room
you think you can make them fall over
good jody anything else in the room you
can move
[Music]
that's it i'm sorry but i'm done
okay jody honey the experiment is over
the door's locked nope kathleen is not
locked it's probably just stuck give us
a moment
calm down kathleen go get the door
you have to stop now jody the test is
over
oh jody it's over jody
it's over it's over
it will never be over
you